well Senegal buys half of its wheat from
Russia and six percent from Ukraine but
the ongoing War has hampered those
Imports and sent prizes Rising
now it has prompted a push in Senegal
for more locally sourced cereals and
that at least has given farmers and
local businesses a boost
in this region of Western Senegal most
Farmers cultivate Millet a local high
protein grain eaten for breakfast and
supper traditionally Farmers have kept
the grain for domestic use but now there
is a push to expand production in a way
that will benefit local economies and
reduce Reliance on wheat
Regional agricultural associations and a
local NGO are providing training and
equipment to Farmers like nagane SAR
they have also encouraged him to switch
to organic farming
I'm seeing all the advantages before we
were using chemical fertilizers but it's
expensive and now I also know that it's
toxic with the new method there are
higher yields and fewer expenses organic
fertilizers last longer in the ground
and even when you have two types of
crops it's efficient for both
the improved yield has enabled nagangi
to better provide for his family the
Millet sold by Farmers like him is
bought by bakeries
and other businesses in the community
including by entrepreneurs such as agua
Diop
she is now using locally sourced Millet
and Maize to make her fritters rather
than imported wheat
I couldn't go back clients have started
to appreciate the Millet fritters that's
what I'm known for
it's our tradition militant maze are
irreplaceable it's also easier to digest
than wheat flour
but one big question is whether people
in cities and other parts of Senegal
would also be happy to switch from wheat
to cereals such as millet
many Senegalese prefer wheat baguettes
of the type sold in this Bakery the
government is encouraging Bakers to use
local cereals because as the price of
wheat Rises so too do the subsidies that
they pay this Bakery is making gradual
changes but convincing customers here
remains a challenge
I think there's still a lack of
information we're trying to sensitize
people to say it's good for them and
every time we explain this the
consumption increases
it represented only two to three percent
of the total sales
today it's at twenty percent my
objective is to reach 50 of sales for
bread made with local cereals
shifting away from wheat
representatives from eight other
countries in West Africa recently came
to Dakar for the launch of a
confederation of West African bakeries
with the crisis in Ukraine we thought
there's a need to find alternative
Solutions today bringing Bakers from
West Africa as a first here in Dakar
there's a need for synergy we want West
Africa to wake up we want to make
commercial exchanges if I want banana
flower for Senegal I can import it from
the Ivory Coast and if an ivorian wants
millet flour he will import it from
Niger or Senegal that's the purpose
whether the use of local cereals will
reach its full potential remains to be
seen eating habits are slow to change
the hope is that at some point the
country will be able to reduce its
Reliance on imported wheat